Hehe...
4-Head, Swift, Rage, PJ, Salt and Failed Fish, Life was easy, Spammin' all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feelin' fine, Twitchy Moos, on the road.
Excellent, 5-Head, Kappa Bride, Kikona Easy, Peepofat, Pepega Aim.
So, da Franke AZ.
Ein bisschen groß vielleicht.
Ah, ja, ja.
Excellent, PogChamp.
So, auf geht's.
Also, ich hab mir was gekauft.
Jetzt hab ich euch ja schon vor der Weile gezeigt, dass ich mir was gekauft hab.
Nämlich, das da.
Das da.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Also billig, billig China Crab, geht's bestimmt noch billiger.
Geht's bestimmt noch viel billiger.
Das Ding heißt, warte mal, ich kopier das grad mal rein, ich hab mir den Namen hier irgendwo aufgeschrieben.
Ja, jetzt bestimmt noch viel billiger.
So, und was das ist?
Was ist noch irgendwo billiger?
Na, nicht wirklich.
Was das ist, das ist ein Schalter für USB-Geräte.
Also sprich, man stöpselt das hier irgendwo ein und dort stöpselt man das USB-Gerät ein.
Und da ist ein Schalter drauf und man kann Remote, also so wie dieses hier zeigt, zum Beispiel über die China App, die wir natürlich nicht verwenden,
man kann über die App oder über, wenn wir es geflasht haben, kann man das USB-Gerät dann oder die USB-Geräte ein- und ausschalten.
Also es ist im Prinzip wie eine Steckdose, also irgendwie eine WLAN-Steckdose, nur für USB.
Ich mein, man braucht ja vielleicht mal was anderes als eine Steckdose, man hat so viele USB-Geräte.
Wofür ich das verwenden werde, ist folgendes.
Ich hab ja ein paar Raspberry Pi Zeroes, zum Beispiel einen für die Kamera an der Haustür, einen für im Keller, die auslesen von der Heizung.
Und wenn die Raspberry Pies mal, sei es WLAN-Probleme, also wenn mein WLAN mal gespuckt hat, wenn die Raspberry Pies aus irgendwelchen Gründen abgekackt sind,
ich muss so ungefähr einmal im halben Jahr, je nachdem was war, mal in den Keller und muss den Raspberry Pi rausziehen und wieder reinmachen.
Das ist, weil das WLAN irgendwas hat oder was irgendwie rumgespuckt hat, aber einmal im halben Jahr ist übertrieben, einmal im Jahr vielleicht.
Und ich werde das jetzt für alle Sachen verwenden, weil ich hab mir natürlich gleich, ihr kennt mich ja, ich hab mir gleich einen 10er-Pack bestellt.
Und ich werde das verwenden für alle Geräte, wo ich nicht rankomme.
Aber reagieren die nicht allergisch drauf, wenn man denen einfach den Strom klaut?
Doch, tun sie, aber wenn ich den Stecker rausziehe, mach ich auch nichts anderes.
Ist ja kein Unterschied, ne?
Also das ist eh die letzte Möglichkeit.
Wo ich das beispielsweise auch einbauen werde ist, vielleicht auch ohne das Plastik drumrum, ist bei mir in die Tür-Gegensprechanlage,
wo ich einen ESP32 drinne hab, für erkennen, ob die Klingel klingelt.
Sollte der nämlich mal irgendwann Probleme haben, dann muss ich die ganze Dose aufmachen und ausbauen und sonst was, um die neu zu starten.
Da kommt auch so ein Ding rein.
Also an sich eigentlich eine enorm praktische Geschichte, im Prinzip eine WLAN-Steckdose für USB.
Das Dumme dabei ist nur, dass die da wollen, dass man das mit so einer komischen App bedient.
Das mach ich natürlich nicht, die wird custom flashed.
So, und was ich da gefunden habe ist eine Anleitung, ich hab auch ein Anleitungsvideo gefunden,
wie man das Ding flashen kann und wie man das Motor drauf machen kann.
Das Motor hatten wir schon öfters mal, unter anderem auf der Kugi-Steckdose-Leiste.
Das Motor ist eine Web-Oberfläche für ESP32, ESP866, Microcontroller, mit der man Geräte steuern kann übers Web-Interface.
Und wenn das Ding an sich nicht schaltet, ja gut, dann hab ich Pech.
Ich mein, den Schalter für den Schalter mach ich da jetzt nicht dran.
Das wäre ein bisschen Overkill, oder? Den Schalter für den Schalter, da brauch ich wieder einen Schalter, um den Schalter zu schalten.
Wenn das Ding abfackelt, also die Chancen mit 5V USB abzufackeln ist relativ gering.
Zumindest nicht insofern, zumindest nicht so, dass es irgendwie mit Flammen aufgeht.
So, und, ja was ist, ach guck mal, die haben ein Video.
Moment, wir gucken uns mal das Video vom Hersteller an. Mal gucken wir uns, der Hersteller erklärt, wie man das verwendet.
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht Monka Tost, weil das ist ein AliExpress-Video.
Moment, ist das Chinesisch?
Was denn?
What?
Ist das, ist das Chinesische Alexa?
Was?
Ah, okay, ja hier, jetzt kriegen wir es gezeigt, der Ventilator geht an.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, also so, so werden wir es nicht verwenden, wir werden das mit TASMOTA machen.
By the way, mein Browser geht nicht mehr, das ist kaputt.
Warum auch immer, jetzt geht er wieder.
Keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hatte.
So, was ich jetzt schon gemacht habe, zeige euch mal, ich habe hier mein Album, habe übrigens irgendwelche Questions übersehen vielleicht.
Ja, ich habe eine Subscription übersehen.
GWOZ13Kuschrender abonniert mit Twitch Prime, 10 Monate am Start, exzellent Subscription.
Wo ist er?
Da ist er am Start, perfekt.
Massive IQ Boost.
So, und ich, also ich zeige euch mal, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe nämlich schon dran gelötet, das mache ich jetzt nicht im Stream, weil das war ganz schön Formulerei.
Also hier seht ihr das Ding, so, und jetzt zoomen wir da mal ran.
Also ihr seht hier mal, da Krümel, ja, okay.
Leute, das ist echt klein.
Das ist echt klein, glaubt's mir.
Das da dran zu löten, das war wirklich nicht einfach.
Ihr seht's ja, ne, also das ist so eine Unterlage, die man auf dem Küchentich hat.
Und das hier sind zum Beispiel Widerstände, also SMD-Widerstände, und das sind die Pins zum Anlöten.
Also das ist wirklich ziemlich klein.
Und man sieht hier noch, man sieht hier noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das habe ich noch zu einem Album, das, das, das ist der Adapter, mit dem man flasht.
Also das ist der Adapter, mit dem man flasht, wo das alles dran kommt letztendlich.
Kann ich gleich noch zeigen, außer Krümelos.
Also hier, man sieht die einzelnen Pins, die letztendlich auf den ESP 32, 82, 66 ist das.
So, und hier sieht man halt die ganze Konstruktion im Endeffekt.
Das ist der Adapter zum, ich hab's auf den Küchentich geschmissen unten, ja.
Also das ist der Adapter zum Flaschen, den man braucht.
Und hier ist halt der ganze, der ganze Kram dran.
Das ist ziemlich klein und dementsprechend, ich hoffe mal, dass es funktioniert.
Also dass ich, dass die Pins, dass ich die Pins nicht irgendwie kurzschließe, habe ich folgendermaßen gemacht, wie man es hier sieht.
Ich habe ein Pin unten gemacht, dann ein Pin oben, dann ein Pin unten und dann ein Pin oben.
Also ich hab die Pins immer oben, unten, unten, unten, unten, unten abwechseln gemacht, dass es keinen Kurzschluss gibt.
Ja, so.
Äh, vielleicht soll ich mal Musik anmachen.
Exzellent.
So, und das ist der Adapter zum Flaschen.
Das ist so ein normaler Adapter für ESP 32.
Die einzige Sache ist, was man braucht, dass man ESP in ESP, ich frag mich immer, ersetzt ESP 32 durch ESP 86 im Kopf.
Ähm, man muss eine Sache machen und zwar, also das hier ist das Pinlayout von dem Ding.
Oben ist 3,3 Volt, unten ist Ground, also sprich da, also Moment, äh, da ist 3,3 Volt und da ist Ground auf der Seite.
Und was man machen muss, damit ein ESP 2866 sich flashen lässt, ist folgendes, man muss, ähm, Ground und GPIO 0, GPIO 0 ist der da, die muss man zusammenstöpseln.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache hier hinten an Ground einfach noch was dran und wenn ich das Ding flashen will, dann stecke ich es da rein.
Und das kommt wieder alles ab, wenn es fertig geflasht ist.
So, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt das Ziel, das Ding zu flashen.
So, sollte mein Gelöte nicht halten, haben wir gelitten, weil ich habe schon alles wieder weggeräumt.
Ich werde das jetzt nicht frisch löten im Stream, also wenn das jetzt irgendwie abricht oder so, wenn das hier irgendwie rumspackt, dann haben wir Pech.
Dann haben wir gelitten.
Dann, dann machen wir das nicht.
Aber es hat einen recht stabilen Eindruck gemacht.
Was ist das denn für ein Adapter, das ist ein, äh, FTDI 232, so einer da.
So, genau so ein Teil ist das.
Genau so ein Teil ist das.
So, und wie man das anschließen muss, ist folgendes, ähm, Ground, PCC, das lässt man glaube ich leer.
Und dann RX TX und das lässt man auch leer, wenn ich das jetzt doch richtig, richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Das muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Ich glaube, das lässt man, lässt man leer.
Blöd FPS.
Ja, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich habe mir extra noch eine Webcam gekauft, die, so eine kleine Webcam, die ich an meinem, ähm, Werk-Basteltisch montieren könnte.
Das heißt, wir könnten theoretisch sogar mal was zusammen basteln und löten im Stream.
Dem muss, muss aber die Kamera halt fixieren, dass nicht hier, äh, äh, aus Versehen liegt.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich dann 500 Zuschauer, weil alle wissen, vor allem, ob ich mich leake, weil ich mich selbst zu doof anstelle.
Okay, ich sehe, der Chat kennt sich aus.
Der Chat sagt hier schon, wird nicht benötigt.
Dann habe ich das Ganze richtig in Erinnerung gehabt.
Ähm, wie gesagt, einzige, was man machen muss, ist GPIO 0 und Crown zusammenstöpseln.
Aber das werde ich dann hier hinten machen.
Da, da, da kommt dann der gelbe Stecker in den, in den, in den, ähm, schwarzen Stecker und dann ist gut.
Dann, dann geht es hoffentlich, ja.
Also es müsste, also es, für mich sieht das so aus, als habe ich alles richtig gemacht.
Ähm, man erkennt es jetzt hier leider nicht so ganz.
Es ist halt echt klein.
Es ist alles relativ fest, sofern das an so kleinem Kram überhaupt richtig fest zu machen geht.
Es sieht für mich auch so aus, als gibt es keinen Kurzschluss.
Also schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal.
Ja.
So, das probieren wir jetzt.
Probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ähm, ich werde mal meine VM starten.
Exzellent Desktop.
Den Desktop habe ich ja extra für euch so gemacht, wisst ihr ja.
Am besten finde ich ja eh die Geräte, die man über die, über, über das WLAN, das Motor flashen kann.
Leider, leider geht das, geht das hier nicht.
Die Musik ist ein Ticken laut, oder?
Oder geht?
Ne, geht eigentlich.
Die ist ja relativ entspannt, da, da muss man sich jetzt keine Gedanken machen.
Was wird es, wenn es fertig ist?
Das ist ein Schalter für USB-Geräte.
Also sprich, da kannst du zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi, der am Arsch der Welt steht.
Ach, die Musik.
Ah ne, geht die Musik.
Kannste damit neu starten, sollte der abgekackt sein oder sich aufgehonken haben.
Du kannst damit theoretisch jedes exbliebige USB-Gerät anmachen.
Also du könntest auch sagen, ok, ich möchte das Ladegerät für mein iPhone einschalten oder so.
Oder ich stöpsel mein iPhone dran und mach das dann nachts an, was bescheuert ist,
weil ich kann das Kabel auch einfach nachts erst einstöpseln, ja.
Es gibt ja immer mehr Geräte, die keinen normalen Stecker mehr haben, sondern über USB gehen.
Und es gibt relativ viele Anwendungszwecke für WLAN-Steckdosen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, gibt es bestimmt auch viele Anwendungszwecke für WLAN-USB-Schalter,
für WLAN-USB-Steckdosen.
Wo sich USB schalten lässt, jetzt wird es ein bisschen laut.
So, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Jetzt probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
So, das können wir zumachen.
What?
Paper, please.
Möchtet ihr, dass ich aktualisiere oder warum geht da Firefox?
Möchtet ihr, dass ich aktualisiere oder warum geht da Firefox nicht?
Ah, ja, ich muss Firefox aktualisieren, okay.
Wenn er das sagt, dann machen wir das.
Firefox aktualisieren.
Excellent.
Firefox updators.
Firefox.
Gut.
Tasmo Tizer brauchen wir.
Das ist ganz gut, um Tasmota zu flashen.
Der lädt nämlich schon die richtige Firma für das Gerät runter.
Und da kann man auch WLAN-Zeug drüber setzen und sowas.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Was magst du lieber, Abt oder Pacman?
Weder noch J, beste.
J, keine Ahnung, suchen wir mal irgendwas.
Chrome, installieren.
Gutes, beste.
Abt ist auch okay.
Was mir persönlich überhaupt nicht gefällt, ist...
Es ist ja nicht immer Jam, DNF oder wie es jetzt heißt.
Das ganze Red Hat Paketsystem geht massiv auf den Sack.
Alias Ayaya gleich J.
Aber warum?
Was ist das für eine Distribution?
Das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM, das Desktop.
Oder wie es mein Vater sagen würde, Descope.
Der hat ja bis heute nicht verstanden, wie man den Kamer ausspricht.
Descope.
Gibt es das vielleicht als Paket?
Tasmo-Taser, nein.
PIP-Install, auf geht's.
So, da muss ich das Gerät jetzt gleich mal holen und per USB anstöpseln.
Tasmo-Tasmo-Taser.
Sieht aus wie ein billiges Hacker-Tool.
Aber das ist ganz praktisch.
Wenn man es angeschlossen hat, sieht man hier oben das Gerät.
Und man kann hier schon die Tasmotor-Releases auswählen.
Der lädt die runter und uploadet das richtig.
Gut, jetzt wird es aber vorher etwas komplizierter.
Und zwar, wir müssen uns mal das Bildchen angucken von der ganzen Sache.
Also das Bild brauchen wir hier.
Das Bild brauchen wir, weil ich muss wissen, welches Kabel was ist.
So, ich hole das Gerät jetzt mal und dann stöpsel ich das an meinen Adapter an.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Also, als erstes mal GPIO 0 auf Ground, weil sonst werde ich das auf jeden Fall vergessen.
GPIO 0 auf Ground.
Ich hoffe, das ist drin.
Dann...
RX auf RX, wohlgemerkt nicht RTX.
Auch wenn man das bei den Spiegelungen hier fast annehmen könnte.
Aber es ist nur RX.
RX auf RX, TX auf TX.
Jetzt...
3,3 Volt umstellen.
Ich muss das Ding erstmal umstellen auf 3,3 Volt.
Sonst mache ich wahrscheinlich meinen ESP...
Dann mache ich den Stick kaputt.
Das stellt man hier oben um.
Licht-Driver.
Hier gibt es oben so einen Jumper.
Das ist so richtig oldschool noch, das Ding.
Dann muss man hier oben den Jumper umstellen auf 3,3 Volt.
Sonst macht man es vielleicht kaputt.
Ground.
Das blaue Kabel.
Da hier, guckt.
Das blaue Kabel ist...
Da muss was dran.
Ich hätte den Scheiß nicht abmachen sollen.
Das war blau.
Genau.
Blau, ist das blau?
Blau.
Okay.
Alles dran.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich stöpsel es mal an.
Wenn ich jetzt gleich weg bin...
Dann hat das Ding meinen PC, USB-Port gegrillt.
Inklusive meinem Mainboard.
Aber ich hoffe mal nicht, dass das passiert.
Es wird eh Zeit für einen neuen Computer.
Es wird eh Zeit, Leute.
Okay.
Ich sollte USB mal einstöpseln am Rechner.
Wartet mal.
USB.
Nicht runterfallen.
Wartet mal.
Runterfallen ist eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Nicht runterfallen.
Runterfallen sackt.
Okay.
Oh.
Es blinkt rot.
USB 0.
Das funktioniert besser, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Hopp.
USB 0.
Releases.
Wir nehmen Tasmota Minimal oder Tasmota Light.
Erase.
Tasmotize.
Wow.
What?
Die Permission Denied.
Okay.
Ich muss in die Gruppe rein.
User.
User Mod.
Max muss in UUCP rein.
Ich habe keine Rechte für einen USB-Port gehabt.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Ja.
Jetzt müsste ich auch erstmal so eine Runde
Geldscheine rumschmeißen.
Fuh.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Aber meine Gruppe gibt es kein Geld.
Bei meiner Gruppe gibt es
Massive IQ.
Okay. Release.
Light.
Okay. Tasmotize.
What?
Ah.
Hat er nicht gecheckt, dass ich jetzt in der Gruppe drin bin?
Muss ich mich neu anmelden?
Okay.
Ah. Okay.
Wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf. Ich rebuild jetzt.
Okay.
Eins ist schonmal das Gute.
Der, ähm,
GP8266 scheint
im Flash-Modus zu sein, weil der blinkt nicht.
Der leuchtet durchgängig.
Das ist schonmal ganz gut zu wissen.
Also das heißt,
GPIO, ähm,
GPIO0 auf Ground
scheint schonmal funktioniert zu haben.
Okay.
Jetzt aber. Jetzt aber. Release.
Light.
Tasmotize.
So.
Äh.
Das sieht nicht so gut aus.
Das dauert viel zu lang schon.
Äh.
Ah.
Aha.
Ähm.
Habe ich,
habe ich irgendwas?
Okay.
Okay. Ich glaube, das, ich glaube, das
ist nicht richtig eingestöpselt. Warte, ich mach das nochmal.
Ich, ich stöpsel,
ich stöpsel die Sache nochmal richtig ein.
Ich glaub die sind nicht richtig drin.
So.
Weil eigentlich
ist alles richtig drinne.
Ground ist auch richtig dran,
wird er nicht direkt in flash modus gehen einmal risette nach gp 0 na ja ich habe gerade
das können wir machen ja ja ich ich ziehe mal den strom kurz raus und mache noch mal neue rein
zumindest bootet er nicht das spricht dafür dass das prinzipiell stimmt was ich da gemacht hab
leid flasch blässe r&g gibt es was ist eine gute gut was ist eine alternative zu blässe r&g
leute ein blässe r&g darf man ja nicht mal verwenden das ist ja mocha tos was was gibt
sie für schönes blässe r&g im mod alternative ok das funktioniert so nicht also man erkennt
jetzt ja leider auf dem bild nicht richtig aber die also ich würde also ich würde nicht unbedingt
meine hand dafür ins feuer legen aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass die pins fest sind dass da
unten alles ordentlich mehr ordentlich sofern möglich wie das aber dass alles kontakt hat
auf der seite da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher das sieht auch alles das ist auch alles relativ fest
sofern es so fest es sein kann ja bei so einem mini pin rx tx wechseln muss ich muss ich rx auf
rx stecken und tx auf tx oder muss ich tx auf rx und rx auf tx ihr wisst was ich meine ist das
quasi so wie beim switch woin manchmal ist das verdreht ok ich mache es mal andersrum als ich
jetzt habe exzellent so ich habe es ich habe es umgeströpselt spin 0 release das war es
chat chat big brain chat alda massive brain huge chat exzellent chat alda
guckt euch den guckt guckt euch den chat alda exzellent
der chat der kennt sich aus leute ich hätte da ewig gesucht bis ich das gefunden habe
big brain chat big brain eckermann chat ha resetten du kannst nichts resetten du kannst
nichts resetten der reset pin ist nicht gelötet da ist nichts mit reset nice ok weil ich habe
ins geheimen schon gedacht es wird nichts ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe gedacht es klappt
nicht ich habe gedacht es klappt nicht aber anscheinend exzellent ok weiter gehts wenn
ich das richtige erinnerung habe was hättest du bloß ohne euch gemacht ja chat also zeigt mal
hier der chat der chat ist so big brain also wer hat es zuerst geschrieben rx und tx vertauscht
rx tx auch das haben so viele geschrieben ich wollte gerade sagen ich gifte euch einen
sub aber da müsst ihr irgendwie acht subs giften jetzt instant aber chat chat big brain
massive huge huge brain so also dann mache ich das jetzt mal ab und wenn ich das richtige
erinnerung habe muss ich jetzt zumindest ist es bei anderen tasmotas sachen so jetzt mache
ich einfach mal usb mäßig an das ding und dann müsste ich dann müsste das ding den
netzwerk aufmachen und ich müsste mich mit einem smartphone darauf verbinden können
so weit so weit in der theorie hier probieren wir das probieren wir das mal aus in der zwischenzeit
könnt ihr euch pippe please angucken ich muss nämlich mal kurz aufstehen und das ding in
die steckdose stecken
jetzt kommt das jetzt kommt der moment der wahrheit ich bin jetzt ich gehe jetzt nämlich
auf mein smartphone und guck in dem wlan settings ich habe leider den raspberry pi 4 den ich
hier stehen habe der funktioniert gerade nicht sonst könnten wir das da drüber machen wobei
ne könnte man nicht da liegt ich wieder alle wlan eigentlich gut dass der nicht funktioniert
ich gucke jetzt in die wlan settings ob es dort einen tasmotas ein tasmotas device gibt
ja so excellent
ne da gibt es kein da jetzt jetzt gibt es ein tasmotas device sehr schön network alles
klar ok dann gebe ich mal meine wlan credentials da ein die ich jetzt das was ich jetzt auch
nicht im wtf weil ich jetzt auch nicht im stream machen will mein iphone hat mich übrigens
gerade rausgeschmissen das ist auch richtig big brain wieder gewesen tasmotas auf connecte
mich iphone common bra ok wlan ssit wlan password da muss ich jetzt aufpassen dass
ich das nicht vorles ok save trying to connect to device network device will restart in a
few seconds ja dann dann müssten wir jetzt gleich mit dem browser drauf können da müssten
wir jetzt gleich mit dem browser drauf können wenn das funktioniert ich gucke mal in meinen
router was das ding für eine für eine ip kriegt
aha boah das ging aber schnell leute das war ja mega easy
da ist es das war ja höchstgradig easy das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
ich meine wir sind 34 minuten oder das funktioniert schon
big brain massive ok so jetzt muss ich hier mal in die anleitung gucken was man da machen
muss template macht mal dem template irgendwas ok jetzt weiß ich nicht genau wie das für
das funktioniert ja ich brauche da eine ordentliche anleitung zu
das motor das da das heißt usb sind bei dem ding die beiden data pins durchgeführt data
pins das was da durchgeführt ist hieß er da
mehr gibt es nicht in den einstellungen sonstige das template
hinzufügen ok was macht das template überhaupt dass
wie die belegung ist oder was was ist das für ein usb stick das ist ein schalter
damit kann man usb geräte ein und ausschalten über ein web interface
hier ist das web interface und darüber kann man usb geräte ein ausschalten allerdings
ist es grad nicht configuration und dann was was habt ihr eben geschrieben in den einstellungen
bei sonstiges das template hinzufügen da was und jetzt dort excellent das da hinzufügen
mach ich das mal probieren wir jetzt aus zack zack mqtt enable nee brauchen wir nicht save
device will restart in a few seconds jetzt schauen wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert
das macht nix bei on off er meint ob das ding nur usb power only ist
nee das ist auch data das ist auch data ach das meintest du mit beiden data ja das ist
so das ist so da drüber geht angeblich auch data das probieren wir gleich mal aus das
probieren wir gleich sobald es schaltet probieren wir das aus angeblich geht da drüber auch
data hab ich glaub ich so daraus gelesen hier d plus d minus are connected also data müsste
da drüber gehen so das problem ist das ding macht nix also ich weiß nicht ob man was sehen
sollte ich mach mal ich mach mal ich mach mal ich mach mal mein handy dran was configuration
template wow nee das ist was anderes ja gut aber ich weiß ja gar nicht was ich machen
muss configuration configure template da bin ich ja generic duration muss ich ja vielleicht
noch hier activate setzen activate muss man activate setzen safe ah ah es leuchtet on
off die led ist vertauscht sie leuchtet bei off und sie geht aus bei on big brain china
led ok ich schließe jetzt mal was dran an dass ihr zumindest hören könnt bei usb oder
oh wisst ihr was ich hab mir doch so china usb sticks gekauft china usb sticks wir schließen
jetzt mal die china usb sticks an und gucken ob data darüber funktioniert wobei soll ich
wirklich china usb sticks anschließen ich schließe lieber den sd card reader an für
den raspberry pi ich trau den china usb sticks nicht ich schließe den sd card reader an
und gucken wie man das jetzt hier reinkriegt ok also jetzt hab ich den rechner stecken
der rechner ist noch nicht explodiert weiter geht on auch off und jetzt steck ich mal den
usb sd card reader rein das ist jetzt aber das ist jetzt eine richtig krasse adapter
geschichte usb micro sd card reader auf diesen adapter für für für strom und das ganze
durchgereicht in die lungs vor allem jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ok von der idee her
sollte jetzt gleich der card reader funktionieren ok das funktioniert ja das funktioniert ja
funktioniert das ist die sd karte wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt 41 min live und funktioniert
ja was das für ein schwachsinn guckts euch an micro sd karte geht ja das ist ja nice
so jetzt mal zum beweis das ist auch jetzt mach ichs mal ab jetzt mach ichs mal weg mal
gucken was dann passiert das ist jetzt heraus jetzt er weg aber das hier hat es nicht gecheckt
ja gut linux plug and play und so aber guck jetzt ist er weg jetzt ist die sd karte weg
und zack einschalten ar remember my joys ein refresh sdb ausschalten disconnect refresh
device weg ist funktioniert gg eats easy ass fuck ok das war jetzt echt das war jetzt
echt einfach wofür braucht man das ja wenn du wenn du remote entweder über den browser
manuell vom smartphone vom desktop oder über eine heim automatisierung usb geräte an und
ausschalten willst sei es in sommer im sommer ein usb ventilator sei es eine lichterkette
am weihnachtsbaum oder aber wofür ich verwenden werde ein raspberry pi im keller bin begeistert
bin begeistert wie einfach das funktioniert excellent dann bis morgen ne wobei was mache
ich denn jetzt keck weight wenn es jetzt funktioniert was soll ich denn jetzt machen wenn es funktioniert
das geht einfach code reviews was soll ich denn für code reviews machen hello dankeschön
subscription sechs monate also nicht hello nicky30 schreibt hello dankeschön dann ist
doch das usb netzteil ständig am strom oder kannst du nicht das schalten wenn ich das
in eine wlan steckdose stecken würde dann könnte ich das ausschalten aber wie gesagt
das ist ja kein das ist ja kein usb netzteil das ist ja im prinzip nur ein schalter guck
dir das ding an also das ist kein netzteil das ist mehr oder weniger einfach nur ein
usb mit einem schalter dazwischen cobalt mach ich heute abend nett wolltest du nicht mal
ein video oder ein smart home sender machen ja bestimmt aber da kann ich nicht so einfach
aufnehmen weil ich da zu viel infos liege ja das ist aber geil das funktioniert ja richtig
gut ach ja doch ein problem haben wir noch die leds falsch rum mal gucken ob wir das
mit der falsch rum led noch gebacken kriegen ich mache mal ich mache mal den kartenleser
ich mache mal den kartenleser gerade wieder raus wenn ich da dran komme ich mache mal
den kartenleser wieder raus dass ich es ein und ausschalten kann ohne dass was passiert
die led ist noch falsch rum also aktuell ist es so oft ist die led grün und und on ist
die led aus das ist fail wie greift man dann darüber zu tcp über das web interface du
kannst es auch über du kannst auch einen htp aufruf machen hierhin das geht auch das
ist das ist das web interface vom gerät das da haben wir gerade da drauf geflasht da sieht
der hersteller zwar nicht vor aber nachdem die pins alle noch dran waren am gerät um
das zu flaschen was war kein problem du kannst auch über mqtt du kannst über htp was auch
immer das noch alles kann tommy ich habe keine ahnung was du genau meinst so du kannst über
htp und mqtt drauf zugreifen es gibt so ziemlich keine programmiersprache wo es nicht in htp
klar gibt so wie könnte man jetzt die led configuration template ist jetzt das das was
ich hier ist das jetzt das hier was ich ausgewählt habe ok moment das müssen wir mal user user
non user button relay 1 non non non non lady first non led link ok so also wie könnte ich
dem jetzt beibringen dass die led falsch rum ist ja geht das mal die ip guck mal das ist
invertet led kann das sein led 1 invertet led es leckt moment es leckt wenn ich jebaited
der chat hat es wieder geschafft low brain chat was wird heute kaputt wir haben nichts
kaputt gemacht wir haben es wir haben es funktionieren gemacht also ich habe mir basti w ich habe
mir eine usb usb also es gibt ja wlan steckdosenleiste und das ist eine wlan usb steckdosenleiste
wenn du es so willst das ist quasi usb rein usb raus und in der mitte den schalter das
ganze an ausschalten kann also man kann strom an und ausschalten beziehungsweise usb geräte
damit an und ausschalten die da eingestöpft sind auch remote über den webinterface wie
man hier sieht das webinterface ist natürlich nicht das originale das webinterface ist das
was wir geflasht haben das originale webinterface gibt es nicht man muss so eine hässliche
china app verwenden guck hier so eine kacke china app usb nehmen dass es funktioniert
also stimmt was wollten wir hier machen genau die led ändern weil ich glaube das habe ich
auch im video gesehen dass er das gemacht hat ähm weil das ist jetzt invertet und das ist
nicht invertet vermutlich mal ne hier safe restart excellent seht ihr mal seht ihr wie
schnell das bootet das ding das ist instant wieder da aber so ein esp 32 sput 82 66 sput
ausschalten jetzt ist richtig rum led grün led aus led grün led aus led grün led aus
oh jetzt habe ich kaputt gemacht jetzt habe ich zu schnell eine ausgeschaltet jetzt geht
sie mir oh ich stöpsel das mal kurz ab und woanders wieder rein dass es im zweifelfall
nicht mein computer kaputt macht und auf der anderen seite gehe ich davon aus wenn
boot fix das wieder das wird aber ganz schön warm leute das wird ganz schön warm das ding
angeblich angeblich kann das sogar quick charge es geht wieder es geht wieder man darf
nicht zu schnell klicken man darf nicht zu schnell klicken bekommt das teil noch eine
wasserkühlung monac s da facket nicht die bude ab bei einem 5 volt usb ding bin seit
gerade erst dabei welcher usb schalter ist das der hier der hier ein zini link der nabe
klingt schon einfach mal china china pur zini link xy wf usb usb switch relay so sieht das
ding aus so sieht das ding aus die pins kommen wieder weg das war jetzt bloß dass ich flaschen
konnte so sieht das aus das heißt es ist wirklich klein das kann man auch in unzugängliche
sachen stopf unzugängliche dosen und und ecken stopfen meinung zur per ferrari performance
heute ich habe keinen blassen schimmer ich wusste gar nicht dass heute irgendwas war
wo ferrari performance ist was ich letztlich ich habe letztens gelesen die tour de France
also nicht nicht fahre nicht auto sondern fahrrad die tour de France dieses jahr wird
verschoben und dafür gibt es irgendein virtuelles event da kann man daheim auf irgendeiner rolle
strampeln und quasi mitfahren so und ich habe mir gedacht man müsste eigentlich das richtig
krass jubelten man müsste die man müsste sich mal die software angucken die quasi dass
das das erkennt wie viel man daheim fährt und das übermittelt quasi in die app weil
ansonsten könnte man einfach einen motor dran machen irgendwie ein kleines elektromotor
der dann fährt für mich und ich muss nur gucken ich muss nur gucken dass sie das nicht
als cheating erkennt dann ist der max auf einmal bei der tour de France vorne das wäre
doch was oder taste das braucht man wir reden ja nicht davon dass wir das an computer anschließen
ich stöpsel das im keller dran und im keller hängt man raspberry pi dran und wenn der
abstürzt oder der stürzt nicht wirklich ab aber manchmal hat das wlan problem und
kommt nicht richtig in keller der raspberry pi mag das nicht und und hängt dann und verbindet
sich nicht mehr zum wlan also ich muss einmal im jahr in keller vom raspberry pi den stecker
ziehen und wieder rein stecken und das kann ich mir zum beispiel damit sparen da gehe
ich nämlich einfach remote hier drauf geh ich ins web interface und sag ok raspberry
pi im keller zack aus zack an bäm geht wieder 200 kilo mein gewinnturte frau also ich ich
kann mich zwar mit dem pepo fat emote identifizieren aber 200 kilo sind es dann auch wiederum nicht
ja bekommst da kein lahn kabel hin nö warum sollte ich ein lahn kabel hin bekommen das
ist im keller durch die beton decke oder durch die kellerklappe sind nur 199 das ist ganz
gut dass da unten wlan ist weil der raspberry pi unten macht ja auch die abfrage ich zeig
es euch mal weil das ist wirklich ziemlich grafana guckt hier das ist die auswertung
von meiner heizung das ist das was der raspberry pi im keller macht und ab und zu gibt er
mal den geist auf so einmal im jahr und dann kann ich ihn darüber resetten also wir wissen
die pumpe pumpt anscheinend gerade gar nicht er hat keinen bock das aber auch nur die
pumpe für warmen wasser der brenner geht gar nicht an weil es warme genug ist der geht
nur an wenn einer warme wasser braucht also händewaschen oder so also man sieht monka
corona wird auch die hände gewaschen hier man kann jetzt echt immer genau sehen wann
irgendjemand händegewaschen hat das ist eigentlich witzig immer hier immer hier dass die leute
was nutzt du für eine smart home zentrale home assistant habe ich ja und das hier liest zum
beispiel der raspberry pi von der heizung aus und wenn der raspberry pi rumspackt dann kann ich
ihn damit neu starten das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut poggers gut ich habe mir ja zehn stück
bestellt ehrlich gesagt was ich mit zehn stück machen habe ich mache habe ich wirklich keine
ahnung also zehn stück aber ihr wisst ja ich bestelle mir bei allem entweder drei fünf oder
zehn das habe ich ja schon ein paar mal erzählt das ist so meine meine stand mein richtwert so
excellent ja aber nice ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das so schnell funktioniert ich bin ich
bin wirklich begeistert begeistert moin tarn schäfer zehn autos easy money easy kein problem
also wie gesagt nicki 30 ich benutze home assistant als ich benutze home assistant als
smart home steuerung kann ich jedem auch nur empfehlen es gibt saumäßig viele module man
kann alles irgendwie integrieren und hatten schönes web interface ich habe so schon mal kurz gezeigt
komplett eingerichtet kann ich es euch nicht zeigen weil dann ist zu viel monka leak angesagt
wenn es kaputt geht hast ein ersatzteil ja also was ich mit zehn mache weiß ich wirklich nicht so
genau man also ich meine ich brauche eins für den keller für raspberry im keller ok und ich
brauche eins für die kamera am hoftor so zwei stück von zwei stück verbraucht acht stück noch
übrig nicki ist am überlegen ob i outbroker oder home assistant die frage hat sich bei
mir nicht gestellt weil da war i outbroker als ich damit angefangen haben mit der smart
home geschichte war ich freue mich jetzt freue mich komme ich dass die led angeht das macht
zwar nix aber genau da war i outbroker noch in den kinderschuhen bei mir hat sich die frage
nicht gestellt ob i outbroker oder home assistant aber ich glaube gerade wenn man ein cooles web
interface will was wichtig ist wenn es vielleicht die frau die freundin mutter opa oma wer auch
immer verwenden soll dann ist ein web interface wichtiger als vielleicht die ein oder andere
funktion weil das sind halt nups und nups gucken zuerst auf ein hübsches web interface man nennt
das man nennt das nicht umsonst den waff den woman acceptance factor das muss hübsch aussehen
das ist genauso warum weil manche leute ihre fritz box hinterm schrank verstecken müssen weil
es ihrer frau nicht gefällt ja gut für opa oma große buttons ja aber leute ich bin ich bin
echt begeistert dass es so einfach geht guck mal knapp eine stunde on geht tut macht led
funktioniert jetzt auch ich bin ich bin echt begeistert was soll ich jetzt noch mal wahnsinn
echt echt poggers ja wie liest du die daten der heizung aus da habe ich mich da habe ich da haben
wir einen kompletten stream mitgemacht nur mal ganz kurz zur erklärung wie ich das mit der
heizung mache also wie ich an die daten von der heizung komme ich habe eine wiesmann wiesmann
veto dennz 222 f ist das glaube ich man kann sich mittlerweile schon die nummer von der heizung
merken ist schlimm genau sowas hier hier sieht man beide bei auch mein weinkeller hier noch
ein schöneres bild von meinem weinkeller excellent wo haben die eigentlich bild von meinem keller
her verstehe ich nicht zumindest vorne an dieser heizung genau hier hast du ein interface
ob to link hast du ein also hier vorne ist ein opto link interface das sieht so aus
genau moment moment so sieht das aus ja super high res bild also im prinzip sieht das so aus
da ist so ein so ein so ein fau und da stöpselt man das hier rein das sind zwei infrared leds die
mit der heizung kommunizieren und usb geht an den raspberry pi 0 und auf dem raspberry pi 0 läuft
ein läuft diese software die die daten auslesen kann die software die die daten von der heizung
auslesen kann und dann haben wir in einem stream selber was programmiert was da was aus diesen
daten die von der heizung ausgelesen werden haben wir den prometheus exporter programmiert
der wunderbar mit grafana zusammen funktioniert so und es läuft jetzt seit seit einem dreiviertel
jahr schon und oder oder nein nicht ganz seit einem halben jahr und liefert mir schöne
daten zu meiner heizung kann doch sagen hier last last sechs monate also lange hebe ich das nicht
auf ok wie lang wie lange habe ich denn meine daten auf ok in einem halben monat habe ich meine
daten auf das reicht da in der regel ja jetzt kann ich mir meine heizungsauslastung angucken
ist doch echt nice so so mache ich das so funktioniert das also wie gesagt brauchst du
wie ist man optokoppler opto opto link kabel kann man sich selbst bauen billiger oder für viel zu
viel geld kaufen das ist im prinzip die 68 euro nicht wert kann man einfach selbst basteln aber
ich habe mir damals auch ein fertiges gekauft wie viele raspberry pies hast du da haben wir
irgendwo ein textdokument in dem das drinnen steht chat die frage ist nur in welchem textdokument
steht das drinnen projekt ideen vodafone stream ide auf wachen stream events merken video ideen
to dos idees poggers netzwerk notes nass bild wo steht das drin leute ich weiß genau wir haben
textdokument wo das drin steht oh nee wo habe ich das weil ich kriege das ich kriege das nicht
mehr aus dem kopf zusammen haben wir das in der anderen vm ich suche jetzt lieber das textdokument
bevor ich da wieder eine halbe stunde hier sind sie mir gedanken drüber machen wo ich
irgendwelche sachen stehen haben wusstest du dass dein aufgeräumter desktop hilft sachen zu
finden ja das am desktop liegt das nicht liegt daran dass das nicht hier drauf ist haben wir
hier irgendwas gehabt wirst du was haben wir hier piece was aber hier ist hier drin ja rechner
ja wo habe ich das also gut dann muss ich da muss ich das doch noch mal ich weiß genau dass
ich das aufgeschrieben habe ich weiß genau dass ich das aufgeschrieben habe ich weiß
bestimmt in stream corona greb raspberry 5 4
ja
dann wird das nix ok dann versuche ich das vielleicht notes
ok dann probiere ich mal aus dem kopf zusammenzukriegen jetzt
schau mal im papier kommt warum warum finde ich das denn jetzt ich kann doch nicht sein
ich weiß genau dass ich das aufgeschrieben habe 100 pro
und kacke rona ok greb esp
bei esp da ist es doch exzellent also das steht es doch jetzt kann ich das vor jetzt kann ich dir
sagen was ich habe also für die kamera am hoftor einen raspberry pi 0w für die heizungsstatistik
sammeln den keller einen raspberry pi 0w für den 3d drucker einen raspberry pi 3 mit octopi im
wohnzimmer ein oldroid hc 2 mit tv head an drauf zum fernseher aufnehmen fernseher gucken fernseher
aufnehmen das ist auch so ein bisschen so was ähnliches wie ein raspberry pi so ein single
board computer allerdings kann man dort direkt eine festplatte anschließen hier guck so sieht
das ganze dann aus also das ist quasi so ein fertiges gehäuse mit platte und hier hinten
ist ein single board computer dran ist ist relativ ähnlich zum raspberry pi und dann
habe ich unten noch eine raspberry pi 3 als unify controller und als frontend für meine ganzen
security camps also sprich ich habe eine am hoftor ich habe eine im hof ich habe einen hinten da
wo die katze immer gerne rumlegt und unten eine im flur und eine im keller so und das ist das
webfrontend wo man sich die kameras angucken kann das haben wir sogar auch im stream mal
zusammengebaut so und esp 32 bzw esp 82 66 habe ich einen dran am stromzähler im keller
kein raspberry pi 4 nieder raspberry pi 4 liegt hier neben mir zu sachen die wir im stream
basteln extra melone das ist ein gutes Wort genau dann habe ich an der tür vorne unten am
ausgang esp 32 hängen der bluetooth low energy pflanz mi flora sensors ausliest das ist ein
sensor der kann messen wie viel also ich habe auf der terrasse stehen relativ viele pflanzen
in töpfen und der kann messen was da für bodenfeuchtigkeit ist wie die sonneneinstrahlung
so ist und und so was da habe ich so 5 6 irgendwie dem dreh mi flora sensor verteilt so sieht das
ding aus kostet übrigens viel zu viel kam aber bengut kaufen für 10 dollar das stück und das
liest der aus dann habe ich in esp 32 am hoftor das funktioniert gerade nicht das bzw das hat
noch nie richtig funktioniert da ist ein schalter dran der erkennt wenn das hoftor auf und zu geht
und der oder ein zweiter soll in zukunft auch gucken ob der briefkasten aufgemacht wird und
zugemacht wird genau da gibt es auch ein bodenfeuchtigkeit zum auslesen esp 32 mit
lorra der überträgt daten von ungefähr 1,2 kilometer entfernung funktioniert erstaunlich gut
mit batterie also das übertragen das macht er gerade nicht aber das übertragen funktioniert
gut für den briefkasten kannst du den vibrator sensor nehmen na bei uns ich bin gegen ich wohne
gegenüber vom bahnhof da vibriert so oft also was ich machen werde ich werde ein infrarot sensor
eher kein frotenden infraschall ein ultraschall sensor nehmen eventuell mal gucken der kann
abstand messen oder weiß ich nicht genau muss mal gucken ja es kommt übrigens jetzt noch einer
dabei es kommt noch ein esp 286 dabei habe ich ganz vergessen an die waschmaschine nehme ich
genau weil ich sie nämlich gerade gelesen habe hast du mich mit rüttel sensor nennt sich sowas
der kann nämlich erkennen wenn die waschmaschine fast fertig ist das ist richtig big brain die
waschmaschine hat keine möglichkeit irgendwie dass man daten abgreifen kann aber sagen wir
so so eine viertel stunde 20 minuten bevor sie fertig ist schleudert die und da mache ich
rüttel sensor dran und wenn die waschmaschine quasi anfängt zu schleudern dann dann kann
ich einen pop-up machen wäsche in 15 minuten fertig das ist ziemlich big brain oder genau
den habe ich vergessen so das ist was ich alles in betrieb habe was mir gerade so einfällt
jetzt weißt du bescheid
wie viele netzwerkfähige geräte sind bei dir insgesamt dauerhaft in betrieb keine ahnung
keine ahnung 30 also wenn du die esp und so alles mit zählt 30 35 oder so 40 ich habe
keine ahnung legit ich habe wirklich kein plan warum auch wozu warum sollte ich das auch zählen
du hast auch viel mit laura warn das ist was richtig cooles ja also was ich damit mache
ist also laura warn wer es nicht kennt nur mal kurz zur erklärung das ist eine wireless
datenübertragungs technologie die darauf ausgelegt ist dass man möglichst weite strecken
also dass man weite strecken damit überbrücken kann die datenrate ist halt langsam also die
ist im vergleich zu wlan abkundtief langsam also wohin wohingegen wir bei wlan von megabits
die sekunde kunde reden und manche jetzt auch sogar schon mit gigabits die sekunde
reden bei wlan reden wir bei laura warn wenn es hochkommt in bytes die sekunde je nach
dem wie man das ganze ttgw okay den kenne ich nicht also ich habe bisher als laura base station
t-beam sowas hier im einsatz sowas hier als basis station bei mir und auf dem friedhof
wo das gegenstück steht da habe ich ein esp 32 fire beetle im einsatz weil der braucht
sehr wenig eidl bzw deep sleep current also der hält über ein jahr an der an der batterie
die geldwest von mikrotik sind gut ja also ich komme damit gut hin ich habe auf ich habe
bei mir hier das eine geld fest stehen und das andere ist halt einem esp 32 mit einem
eigenen laura module dran funktioniert erstaunlich gut warum friedhof weil big brain wohlgemerkt
das läuft gerade aktuell nicht aber der plan ist dass also der friedhof dort wo mein opa
liegt wo meine oma liegt das ist ungefähr 1,2 kilometer weg so und nachdem gerade im
sommer immer die frage ist muss man zum friedhof jetzt gießen gehen habe ich dort einfach
einen oder so ist der plan oder es funktioniert auch aber ich habe es dort gerade nicht im
betrieb also ich habe schon alles getestet der bodenfeuchtigkeit sensor funktioniert
die übertragung 1,2 kilometer funktioniert also prinzipiell funktioniert das deswegen
will ich da einen bodenfeuchtigkeit sensor hinstellen der mir keine ahnung drei vier
mal am tag die den stand der bodenfeuchtigkeit überträgt über laura waren also sprich
ungefähr 1,2 kilometer funktioniert gut habe ich schon ausprobiert oder kriege ich immer
mit quasi ob ich gießen gehen muss auf den friedhof oder nicht excellent das sind die
ganz kleinen ne das sind die ganz kleinen runden ja ne ne ok da braucht da braucht man esp 32
mehr ich habe 1200 milliampere stunden akku akku drin in so einer kleinen wasserdichten
box wie versorgst du dir mit spannung wie gesagt 1200 milliampere stunden akku in einer
wasserdichten box das mit dem fire beetle esp 32 funktioniert das erstaun wirklich erstaunlich
gut man muss halt gucken dass man so oft wie möglich im deep sleep ist wenn man nicht
in die wenn man nicht im deep sleep ist hat man halt gelitten habe ich nicht drohm sich
habe ich nicht aber ich habe relativ viel seawave zeugs zum beispiel der sensor hinten im fischteich
ist seawave die ganzen steckdosen die schalten kann sind seawave die temperatursensoren
außen sind seawave jede menge zeug ist seawave bei mir irgendwas wollte ich noch smart lights
bin ich bin ich so ein bisschen dabei seit letztem jahr weihnachten habe ich aber nicht
viel gemacht kann man einen raspberry warte mal wollte ich nicht noch irgendwas anderes
beantworten grad ich hab doch grad mit irgendwas irgendwas angefangen zu beantworten hab da
mittendrin aufgehört magnet schalter für den briefkasten geht schlecht das ding ist
aus metall was funktioniert wir einfach ein stinknormaler schalter vorne dran ja ich wollte
doch kein irgendwas beantworten hab dann mittendrin wieder mal aufgehört magnet schalter funktioniert
nicht richtig auf metall nein hab ich doch schon ausprobiert das klappt nicht hast du
schon im krankenhaus vorgestern geschickt ein ok was auch immer also kann man einen
raspberry pi als server nutzen für kt sserver und so ja klar kann man also ich hab also
king wall ich kann dir sagen warum es bei mir nicht funktioniert hat ich hatte mal
einen seawave door sensor den also extra outdoor der funktioniert ja auch so dass du auf der
einen seite hast du auf der einen seite hast halt den sensor auf der anderen seite hast
ein stück stück magnet und wenn die tür zugeht dann geht halt der magnet auf den sensor
und das hat nicht funktioniert im metalltor sobald das am metall war schaust du eigentlich
serienfilme ja ab und zu der funktioniert ok ja aber das glaube ich auf was anderes
auf was basiert der ja ok das ist ja auch was anderes der funktioniert der funktioniert
das kann ich das das kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass der funktioniert ich speichere das mal
das ist nicht schlecht was ich jetzt aktuell ab ich habe einfach so ein schalter hinten
dran also ich habe ich habe einfach nen schalter der der bewegt wird wenn das hoftor geöffnet
wird ja aber zu der frage hier oben mit dem mit dem raspberry pi klar kannst du machen
spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen also der ist dafür geradezu prädestiniert dass du
ein raspberry pi für so kleinen kram nimmst da brauchst du noch nicht mal ein raspberry
pi 4 oder so ts brauch ja nichts großartig also leistungsmäßig reicht ein raspberry
pi dicker aus für hosting geschichten was sowas in der richtung aber man muss sagen
wofür ein raspberry pi nicht gut ist ist nass nass ist nass ist immer das erste was die
leute bauen wollen aber gerade da ist der raspberry pi auch dafür jetzt nicht sonderlich
gut der raspberry pi 4 ist was das angeht sowohl von den schnittstellen her als auch
von der cpu leistung her und den cpu features nicht das beste nass gerät erstens ist die
io einbindung immer noch nicht so der wahnsinn aber nicht das große problem das eigentliche
problem was den raspberry pi 4 zu einem relativ schlechten nass server macht ist dass die
sich gedacht haben sie zertifizieren oder oder sie sie lizenzieren die krypto funktionen
von der armen cpu nicht und dementsprechend hast du jetzt zwar eine armen cpu auf dem
raspberry pi 4 drauf die theoretisch krypto extensions hätte hat sie aber nicht weil
sie da gespart haben und das heißt sobald du die festplatte verschlüsseln willst die
dran ist ist der raspberry pi 4 richtig krass langsam also wir reden dann so von 30 mb die
sekunde oder so 25 mb 30 mb die sekunde das macht da macht das mit dem nass nicht so viel
spaß was sammle ich eigentlich die ganze zeit für punkte
schwachsinn piss dich alde cortana ja so sieht aus leute so sieht aus also wie gesagt ich
bin immer noch echt begeistert wie einfach das jetzt funktioniert hat das ist was guck
mal jetzt wo ich das grad sehe die dose von meiner tür gegen spreche von meiner genau
gegen spreche telefon hier oben da hinten steckt der sp 32 jetzt drin und da könnte
ich ohne probleme noch so ein schalter mit rein machen was kann man denn gut für nass
benutzen wenn es wirklich richtig gut performance haben sollt die low budget low power intel
geschichten sind ganz gut das ist halt ein normales x86 die otroid geschichten sind also
sowas hier zum beispiel die dinger sind auch ganz ganz okay die sind ein ticken schneller
was das angeht wie der raspberry pi ich meine das ist wirklich die lite variante mit nur
einer festplatte drin aber ich würde empfehlen wenn du nass selbst bauen willst und willst
auch was mit ordentlich performance haben dann nehmen zum beispiel sowas dann nehmen
sowas hier oder oder eine der neueren da hast du genug performance kostet halt das doppelte
von dem raspberry pi ungefähr das bord ist aber der cpu schon dabei aber da hast du
halt ordentlich performance dabei mit sowas in der in dieser richtung ja genau oder wieder
king wall sagt es spricht auch nichts dagegen sich ein fertiges sein oder qnap oder sonst
was zu holen könntest du mal bitte grundlagen in docker zeigen versuche gerade ein bisschen
einzusteigen wir haben letztens im stream vorgestern haben wir folgendes gemacht das
könnt ihr wahrscheinlich gefallen wenn du grad docker grundlagen machst vorgestern
haben wir sowas hier oder vorvorgestern haben wir sowas hier im stream gemacht sowas hier
oder reverse proxy mit docker traffic let's encrypt da haben wir jetzt natürlich keine
so richtig docker basics gemacht also wie macht man docker file und container stoppen starten
volumes mounten ich glaube aber was dafür besser ist ich meine wir können sowas mal
im stream machen wenn ihr das wollt aber ich glaube dafür ist besser man guckt sich einfach
auf youtube den docker kurs an es gibt auf youtube richtig gute docker kurse docker kurs
vier ich habe letztens eingesehen gegen vier stunden oder fünf stunden die kann man sich
wirklich geben und dann weißt du bescheid und wenn du denkst ok ich weiß trotzdem noch
nicht bescheid wahrscheinlich weißt du dann bescheid es gibt mal docker nicht allzu viel
wo man bescheid worüber man bescheid wissen muss wenn man das verwenden will du brauchst
da nicht so viele sachen damit das ordentlich verwenden kannst bengut auch gerade sind wir
17 ja leute ich würde sagen also gibt es gibt es noch gibt es noch irgendwelche sachen die wir
besprechen müssen ja könntest du einen vibrations sensor empfehlen finde ja also ich kann dir
ich kann dir die zeigen die ich habe aber da weiß ich wie gut die funktionieren ich weiß
gar nicht wie die hieß das ding ich rüttel rüttel wie hieß das denn sensor shake ne
erschütterung so was jeder kannst du die hab im moment das sind nicht die die ich hab
ob die gibt es nicht mehr die ich hab musst du dich ein bisschen umgucken man kann da nicht so
viel verkehrt machen behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal was ganz praktisch ist in sensoren die sowohl
einen digitalen ausgang haben als auch einen analogen ausgang ich weiß ich ob das jeder fall
ist ja erkennt man ist nicht so genau digital also sensoren die den analogen und digitalen
ausgang hat sind ganz praktisch weil da kann man folgendes machen man kann entweder sagen mich
interessiert nur wenn es über einem gewissen wert ist und hier kann man quasi die einstellen
wie empfindlich das ganze ist oder man macht es mit dem man macht es mit dem analogen output ran
und man sieht alle werte und kann das selbst machen in der logik dass sensoren die digital
out und analog out haben sind immer sehr praktisch was haiku os ist es das bios nachfolger ding ja
ja das kenne ich das kenne ich habe ich auch nie verwendet allerdings muss man sagen wirklich
benutzbar ist es ja nicht aber ich schreibe es mal auf und wenn man elektronik bestellt
versucht nach möglichkeit nicht einer packs zu bestellen erstens also vor allem vor allem nicht
in deutschland weil das ist so teuer hier 5 49 das ding kostet bei aliexpress 40 cent wahrscheinlich
weil erstens wenn er was kaputt macht oder es geht bei solchen dingen mal recht schnell ja aus
versehen was abgelötet irgendwas kaputt gemacht war wie wie auch immer geht geht relativ drauf
gedrehten aus versehen keiner also die dinger sind ja auch nicht groß kauft immer dreierpacks
wenn ihr euch elektronik zeug kauft zur elektronik baukrams kleinkram kauft immer dreierpacks
was ist denn das so druck sensor oder sowas das ist glaube ich wenn man drauf drückt
aber vibrations sensor ok keine ahnung null ja ok leute mein anbetracht der tatsache dass
dass es gerade keine weiteren fragen gibt und dass ich heute morgen schon mal zwei stunden
gestreamt habe und ich eigentlich gar nicht vor hatte heute abend noch mal zu streben geht jetzt
auf das eine gute frage die beantworten wir jetzt noch schnell würdest du empfehlen irgendeine
klaut selbst zu hausen wenn ja und heute oder server mieten und da hausen das ist ein bisschen
komplizierter also man muss ja sagen dass eine klaut selber hausen außer der name nichts mit
der klaut zu tun hat also wenn du sowas wie top box verwendet kannst du damit zwar dateien
sünken aber was im hintergrund passiert hat nichts mit dem zu tun aber wie wenn du next
klaut verwendest dass next klaut denn diese diese sache mit klaut im namen ist ein bisschen
bisschen gebatet wenn man ehrlich ist das ist eine ganz normale feilsynchro web interface selbst
hausen geschichte die mit der klaut recht also mit mit klaut recht wenig zu tun hat wenn du mal
angenommen du brauchst ein feilsynch dann würde ich mir als erstes überlegen muss es next klaut
sein weil next klaut selbst kann halt noch jede menge andere sachen ja genau sind auch ein paar
was sachen die dabei stehen das ist der grund warum ich auch weg von next klaut will weil ich
nix verwende von von dem was next klaut kann außer feilsynch und der ist der geht mittlerweile aber
ich behaupte mal das ging andere besser hin und ein bisschen für kontakte sync das ist alles
termine sync das ist alles deswegen wenn ich mir gerade überlegen ob ich nicht weg nicht weg
gehe von next klaut so wenn du den kram selbst hausen willst würde ich mal als erstes überlegen
was brauche ich alles muss es wirklich next klaut sein aber gehen wir mal von aus es es muss du
sagst es sollte next klaut sein dann würde ich dir empfehlen macht das daheim zum beispiel auf
den raspberry pi kannst ja auch mittlerweile von der ssd booten in raspberry pi 4 und schau
dass du damit auskommst dass du deine daten züngst wenn du daheim bist du musst das gar
nicht von außen zugreifbar machen du kannst es einfach so machen immer wenn du daheim kommst
sich dein tablet dein dein smartphone und sonst wie im wlan befindet dann züngst du so dann hast du
nämlich keine probleme die du mit irgendwelchen public public geschichten hast so bist du trotzdem
der mein du willst das unbedingt öffentlich im internet zugänglich haben dann würde ich
mal als erstes überlegen also ich würde es prinzipiell nicht auf dem server im internet
hosten also das würde ich das würde ich eigentlich nie machen mit meinem privaten zeug das nächste
was ich mir dann überlegen wird ist ok wenn ich unbedingt von extern drauf zugreifen muss während
ich unterwegs bin da kein weg dran vorbei für und ich auch nicht warten kann bis ich mal abends die
sachen im wlan zünden kann dann würde ich schauen dass ich das über ein vpn mache also sprich du
willst ich per vpn ein und greifst dann auf dein nextcloud zu so und wenn dir das wenn dir das auch
nichts ist wenn du sagst nee da habe ich keinen bock drauf ich will auch nicht erst in vpn starten
war mich eingelogt bin ich will direkt instant browser aufmachen von überall auf der welt
hingreifen können dann und nur dann kannst du dir überlegen das irgendwie freizuschalten von quasi
per port weiter leitung und dann dass ihr was teils sagt auf jeden fall nicht nextcloud selber
freischalten sondern irgendein reverse proxy davor sei es engine ich sei es trafik sei es
kadi sei sonst was irgendwas davor was weiß wie man security autentifizierung und zertifikat
handling macht so und diesen reverse proxy lässt du auch netz encrypt zertifikate machen und am
besten noch mal ein zusätzliches basic os davor dass du dich nicht nur auf die nextcloud
autentifizierung verlassen musst und dann schaltest du der nextcloud frei
aber ich würde wie gesagt ich würde dir gar nicht empfehlen das von außen zugänglich zu machen
hast du einen pw manager oder warum kopierst du ständig random chars wie bringst du das
denn in zusammenhang mit einem passwort manager zwischauflage überschreiben den es macht das
macht übrigens key pass selbst ja ich habe ein passwort manager ich verwende seit jahren
schon oder jahrzehnten fast schon mittlerweile key pass aber das hat nicht mit passwort manager
zu tun dass ich immer einsen kopiere hier hier ist hier hier versuche ich glaube irgendwann mal
zu erklären was nutzt du eigentlich aktuell für den router also ich habe ganz vorne gezwungen
am arsten aktuell noch eine unity media connect box hinter der connect box habe ich einmal eine
fritzbox hängen die billigste 79 euro fritzbox die es gibt die macht deckt und woib weil deckt
und woib was ist was man nicht selber machen will und daneben parallel hängt ein mikrotik router
der alle möglichen netzwerkgeschichten macht an diesem mikrotik router hängt auch meine ganzen
ubiquity access points da hängt auch der 10 gigabit switch dran da hängt auch ein zweiter
noch ein anderer switch dran ja da ist alles dran poe da ist alles dran was netzwerk technisch
gemacht werden muss hängt an diesem mikrotik router die fritzbox wie gesagt macht nur deckt
und woib und was sie auch noch macht ist kontakte sync für das fritz phone was wir auch noch um
gammeln haben welchen mikrotik router hex poe das teil preisleistungsmäßig der beste router den
man sich kaufen kann wohlgemerkt router wir reden hier nicht von einer fritzbox alternative weil
dem gerät fehlt so ziemlich alles was die fritzbox hat weil die fritzbox ist ja auch kein router im
eigentlichen sinn sondern multifunktionsgerät das ding ist hier halt ein router mit aber wirklich
auch schon sehr viele funktionen aber es ist keine fritzbox konkurrent also du hast da keine deckt
basis station drin du hast da kein dsl modem drin oder sonst was einfach nur router oder um
die sysco leute zu erfreuen router kannst du eine windows verschlüsselung empfehlen oder einfach
bittlocker draufknallen veracrypt einzigware veracrypt einzigware software aus frankreich
die ich verwende veracrypt ich gebe zu die seite sieht nicht sonderlich vertrauenswürdig aus aber
das ist der nachfolger von truecrypt das ist das beste was du finden wir finden wir es für
windows klappt das mit windows updates kommt drauf an wenn die windows updates updates sind und keine
neuinstallationen dann klappt das wenn das verkappte neuinstallationen sind dann klappt das nicht
also das klappt nicht du entschlüsselst und verschlüsselst danach wieder das geht habe ich
jetzt auch bei jedem major windows update außer bei den letzten zwei gemacht die letzten zwei
waren nämlich updates alle anderen davor waren so verkappte neuinstallationen und dann hast du
noch wlans für china gerät ja eins eins für china kram das ist ein eigenes eine eigene wlan
ssid mit einem eigenen wlan drunter für die für die ganzen china dinger und und halt auch für
die china dinger wo ich keine customfirma drauf mache oder nicht drauf machen kann
und auch die wo customfirma drauf ist ist wurscht
gut leute wir sehen uns ich gehe auf bis denn macht's gut zu bis morgen früh denkt
an morgen früh wieder aufwachen stream aufwachen stream wie jeden sonntag zu